yeah welcome to this video playing hmm
shootin I don't know I don't know how to
pronounce that oh I have played him two
times already I have no particular idea
how those games went okay just two games
not not too much okay get the classical
names oh and with d5 yam people play
their logos in quite a bit nowaday so it
might come from from this that they tend
to go d 5 c 6 is a bit strange I mean
it's not particularly bad or anything
but it it doesn't really fit with black
set up the same as with Bishop reform
usually you want to go like c5 and
attack the center what g5 that's um
that's strong strong stuff really hmm
okay yeah let's let's castle long Xia
and see what he's doing here hmm
how to do this here I'd like to open up
the H file but h4 is strategically very
very demanding this move don't know if I
want dad okay maybe do this I have to
play this move probably anyway at some
stage and I'm not quite sure how I play
here maybe add for was interesting ok
let's go F 1 p-5 is I don't know and
this is a strange game because i never i
didn't understand any of his moves not
in the slightest now I'm threatening
also f5 ok this is a movie understand
because f5 was a big threat ok I can
take but this weakening quite a bit
maybe here threatening 95 and preparing
age 4
c5 is interesting now trying to trap
trap my bishop a three-year trapping his
bishop but he has got see form
hey that's a tricky thing tricky
business mercy for I can actually take
because of the pin he has rook c8 but
the pin is still on so wow so Queen B 6
said you don't get it okay so if I'm
playing the queen bee three no way then
it takes with the pawn Knight divorce
awesome maybe 90 for attacking e6
96 and then queen bee six is getting
this back okay
and okay whatever we had game yeah I
probably played tons of kerala museum
that should have been over long ago with
all those all those Becky moves by black
came let's get the King King a little
bit all of that so let me just just TM a
checking be seven
okay to just covers it like that I
wonder if age 4 is a move on it's this
is nonsense okay maybe I can get rid of
this rook the rook is really a pest down
on c4
yeah afterwards the computer will
probably show tons of better moves for
me a strange
yeah I'm a pawn down or not no it's
mieko sequel material actually yeah
maybe i'm still okay here i was taking a
long time to be honest why I was a
little bit irritated at the start now
that he has tons of games in he played
many moves that are very computer is
actually this g5 and so on this is how a
bad computer would play but ok yes too
many games and to be a cheat so let's
see i can i can take and quinn be six
maybe should be a pretty decent end game
because of my activity in case of a
queen trade i have a good position with
the protected pawn on e5 and the sea
pawn is more of a weakness I don't know
if you I don't know candy candy this is
a way to avoid the direct Queen trade I
can take take the power now see you
three check but really this is really
just a check and not much more okay if I
go yeah maybe I if I go there yes good
night see five maybe mmm interesting I
can do this going for 96
and now Quincy three maybe or is the
bottom Quincy 3 4 94 is BS time warning
has tricks there with night a 4 and 93
he's in this pin so okay but he s III
check which is annoying
c3 check is a problem I don't get any
move here c3a maybe you can go see three
now check check no night b3 check yeah I
have to do this unfortunately in 19
seconds it's giving me that pawn amazing
maybe g4 I had a six possibly may I
should have done that yeah now is
stopping this
check yeah yeah I will probably lose on
time in a winning position why this why
this winning now I think check check
check nice found site for a trick there
with the H pong champ strange games
strange games them I was really
irritated by to be honest by all this
year because this is this is just this
is quite computer issue this g5 this is
exactly how a bed mobile phone plays and
so now it sounds weird but it's exactly
like that and it is some quite quite
quite weird frankly but ok I didn't
didn't refute it so I probably just
missed the turn of winds here and it's
just hard to believe that this should be
any good ok taking here rook c8 hmm John
Bishop g5 but it's not winning Knight d4
seems to be better yeah ok the night is
strong on deform we had a similar
position in the game this is just a much
better version of it I has to take now
and now here and my king is quite open
but he has to really bad pieces yeah
computer gives why the win here but I it
still trick him here that's also good
for what but not not easy and he tricked
me afterwards so here takes and now
around here I'm losing the threat
yeah this is this is a mistake as weird
as it looks 95 looks look strange in my
book because it runs right into this but
Queen d5 is good for black because c3
threatens my original idea was this move
of course but then he has this and I'm
sure I'm losing the exchange here this
was what I overlooked when I went 96 and
it's quite strange I don't have had move
move here white is lost yeah and this is
also very strong but should be six he
didn't even go for that yeah he went
bishop you six I don't know this is a
very strange game and now I could have
taken g2 and win check check check check
their know now he spoiled it again to to
this check and how do I win f7 is easily
winning him yeah I only had eight second
step so create a pretty pretty bad bad
game and a strange game it's very
irritated by by this opening in recent
times i had many cheaters here and this
sometimes gets to you because this is
really exactly like a bad computer
program place I mean g5 is just an
ridiculous move you can play Bishop e7
or something not weaken himself why
would you voluntarily play this move
it's very strange yeah and yeah sorry i
don't know it's a strange game it
doesn't look like he cheated because he
made many a pretty bad bad tactical
blunders later but this opening still
irritated me I don't know it's a bit
strange maybe I'm a bit paranoid there
because of the recent recent games okay
thanks for watching guys